okay so
i have a personal confession
i have never sat down
and watched a full episode of star wars
clone wars i know i know i know i
totally know like i get that like a lot
of people just like what
yes it's true it's true i've never
watched
like i'm like kurt angle from wwe oh
it's true i've never watched a whole
episode all the way through and i'm
aware of like people who existed in the
clone wars show like ahsoka or osaka i
repronounced her name like i'm aware
that like she exists and like she was in
the show which is how people were
introduced to her and she was a jedi who
did some stuff but i don't really know
much about her right like i don't really
know a whole lot about this chick as i
understand it she's a badass but like i
don't know right i
don't know so i sat down to watch the
first episode right mariah was like you
need to watch the first episode of you
you need to watch the series right
didn't really tell me to watch it but
like i have her reading jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers oh
my god i have her reading that so i got
it so i'm gonna watch this the first
episode man dude this episode was lit
look here's the thing man here is the
thing right so so all right first things
first i'm kind of hoping those little
opening statements that they make right
like little opening words of wisdom i'm
hoping they get like
more depressing and like screwed up as
time goes on you know what i mean i mean
i don't want to be depressed but i'm
just saying it'd be funny right like if
like at the end of the series you get to
like the final episode where it's like
okay so basically all is lost like we're
going into episode three you know how
this turns out and the opening thing is
like yeah
we're all kind of [ __ ] like i'm hoping
that's what it is something along those
lines but i will say the narrator
voiceover in the beginning that kind of
threw me for a loop for a minute there i
was like okay this is a little weird and
i was i was like i mean am i really
going to dig this show
man let me tell you something that
matters
all right look here's the thing here's
the thing right so like this first
episode
it's it's cool because it gives you the
introduction of what's going on with
regards to like the fact that it takes
place during the era of the clone wars
kind of fills you in on what yoda's
doing just being casually op right like
you have this guy who's on this world
and you have like count dooku who's
talking to him and he's like you should
join our side and the guy's like i mean
i will but i want to see what the jedi
have going on so he talks to yoda and
yoda's like you should join our side so
this guy's like okay cool so like here's
what we're gonna do like the the
apprentice of dooku is like how about we
have like a like a fight right like
yoda's guys versus my guys and then
whoever wins that's the side you have to
go on sure because that makes sense hey
guys uh so like basically darth sidious
who is why all standards immediately
he's a sith lord operating as a
chancellor we all knew something was
going on with that guy like the first
time we saw him in episode one we're
like that dude's a bad guy what he's
gonna do i'm not entirely sure but he's
definitely a villain and you'd be
ridiculous to believe otherwise like i
just seem shady you know i mean you ever
meet a person like that in your life and
you're just like okay so i don't know
this person but this guy their life is
going in one of two directions either
they're already a villain who does some
bad stuff or they're gonna be like you
ever meet people like that i've met
people like that right it's like this
person is obviously the villain of
somebody's story so so the whole thing
here is like they're like okay let's
basically boil this all down to what's
effectively a coin flip right like the
future of the galaxy hinges on
a thumb war more or less not really
that's a terrible analogy so like it's
it's one of the cool things because like
the droids come rolling up right like
yoda's got his got like three clone
troopers right now here's the thing
three clone like three clone troopers
those guys are op right those the clone
troopers are nuts they were modeled
after jane gofet they're wildly capable
they got a secret mission to kill all
the jedi that nobody knows about but
nonetheless like they're ridiculously
capable guys right so so so here's the
thing so these guys side with yoda and
yoda's kind of like out there doing his
thing and then you end up having like
the the droids from the separatists who
like show up these folks are rolling up
in tanks right these guys are loaded for
bear right and this is like it's
supposed to be a fair fight right like
four on four that's not really what
happens and that one guy on the planet
the the king ruler guy the the one who
looks like the dude from episode one who
was like who's like anakin was like his
servant or slave or whatever you want to
call like basically like that kind of
looking guy and so it's like okay like
he's a little pissed because he's like
things are supposed to be fair but hey
like we'll
we'll let the chips fall where they may
and we'll just see what happens
man
they just weren't prepared so so these
droids roll in right i mean they got
tanks and all that kind of stuff you got
like these three troopers you got yoda
sitting there he's just just chilling
right like the clone troopers are like
man like i don't know why this guy's
just sitting here relaxing while we're
getting ready to face these tanks and
these droids and stuff like that right
like general yoda's smoking the sheesh
so the the thing about this is like once
these guys roll in yoda's like just have
patience man they can't get in here and
they can't right like just because of
the whole structure of everything right
like they try to roll in they end up
getting blocked by like the
weird-looking alien bushes so they kind
of have to like get out and they have to
go on foot i mean one of them tries to
get through but like at that point yoda
starts unleashing holy hell like these
guys start shooting stuff and like they
almost die when like some of the droids
like the other droids right like those
robocop looking droids when those things
show up right and then like yoda just
kind of casually does away with them a
little bit by making one float in the
air and like shoot all the others so
it's like okay cool this is this is
interesting i can kind of get behind
this a little bit i mean at this point
i'm just kind of like all right i mean
so like stuff's happening and yoda's
doing a few cool things but it's nothing
that like i don't expect to see from
yoda right you know what i mean like
he's just this little op you got it it's
kind of okay you know this is whatever
but the cool thing came when like the
three cloves were down to themselves and
yoda kind of gives them a little bit of
a pep talk and it's like come on guys
cheer up right we're gonna make this out
in one we're gonna be out here in one
piece nobody's gonna be left behind
everything is gonna be copacetic so then
then
yoda goes after all that like goes after
the tanks and the droids by himself man
this little dude this little bastard
this guy's a one-man army dude he's it's
it's crazy right this guy man he's
chopping he's like chopping people up
with his lightsaber he's cutting holes
in the bottom of the tanks but i mean
this guy is just absolutely demolishing
these guys right and it's the craziest
thing because like the whole time the
whole time the droids are trying to kill
him right yoda's running through this
whole thing he's like come come come
feel me and just like start killing
these guys cutting their heads off right
like the apprentice tries to get a hold
of the droid like the main general droid
and another droid pops up and he's like
the general's dead right you know it's
it's literally the scene out of aliens
right one of them's like droids we are
leaving right like we're getting out of
here right and like dude gets his head
chopped off while he's in the middle of
talking to this chick i mean it's a
bloodbath son it's an absolute bloodbath
so literally yoda's killing all these
guys quite literally saves the day by
himself because he's the most op little
son of a [ __ ] there ever was in the
history of star wars so then like you
get that you get back to like the the
main king guy and the apprentice he's
talking to dooku right and he's just
kind of like yeah man i can't join your
side because basically you guys lost it
was supposed to be a fair fight not only
was it an unfair fight on your side you
still couldn't win one jedi literally a
jedi i crushed all you guys now here's
the thing there's a little bit of an
exception here right it is yoda right if
they had sent in like that one twilight
chick they got shot to death on the on
that planet that was full of like giant
mushrooms and stuff it probably wouldn't
have made a difference right or if they
had sent like tim the jedi it probably
wouldn't have done anything right
because tim kind of sucks he's he's i
mean assuming there is a jedi named tim
which i would kind of hope that there is
he's like the guy that like he's got
like a c and jedi right like can you
turn jedi into a verb like can a jedi be
a verb is it a thing you can do right in
the art of jediing tim got a c which
technically he's passing but he's not
the best you know what i mean like he
can kind of get the job done sometimes i
guess but like yoda like he's like the
grand poobah right like literally the
best of the jedi but still right you
know yoda's kind of like hey man now
that we won you got to be on our side he
shows up there dooku is like all right
look i'm not going to take no for an
answer so maybe if you won't agree then
like you're a princess whale right so
like he goes to like have his apprentice
kill that guy lightsabers stop dead in
their tracks and i was like oh son sun
is on now it's on like donkey kong son
man this batman is about to get real
yoda comes walking up and i'm just like
oh dude yoda man what you're gonna do is
you're gonna kill this chick whatever
like i have no idea what goes on she
starts talking trash and yoda's like
here comes a clue train the last stop is
you you're powerful in the force but you
ain't that powerful i'm yoda [ __ ] you
can't touch me right so literally like
he yanks the lightsabers out of her hand
right like literally turns him off and
pulls him out of her hands and he's just
like yeah you got a lot to learn i mean
i literally just took lightsabers out of
your hands come on man like you really
think you got a chance against me girl i
just took your main weapon away from you
and then like i mean what could you do
to me in the force right i mean you
could try to do something to me in the
force but like let's be honest here elmo
clap them cheeks so what ends up
happening is like he gives her
lightsabers back and then she just bails
right she's just like okay yeah i gotta
get out of here i gotta get while the
getting's good right she's she's like
americans moving out of the united
states right now right just like getting
while the getting is good that's
literally what she does
she just pieces out and so ultimately
the guy ends up siding with yoda but
here's the thing man this show it's so
much better than i thought it was and
i'm one episode in as i understand it it
only gets better right it only gets
better of a show i'm sure it's gonna
have its low moments but i'm sure it's
gonna have like its lulls worse it's
kind of like i mean you know okay so
like some stuff happened none of it
mattered it was like the equivalent of
like sitting in the the lobby of the
dentist when you were a kid reading the
highlights magazines you know what i
mean like it's just not a whole lot
doing there you know what i mean like
it's that kind of a thing you know so
i'm sure some of the episodes are going
to be that way but we'll see what
happens having said that i'm in the show
well i'm definitely in this so i'm gonna
i'm gonna keep watching the rest of this
show let me know what you guys think
about clone wars down in the comments
section i'm curious myself thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace